These are six of the 40
courses you would find in a computer
science.
Degree, a four year computer science degree
assuming it is accredited by the ab-e-t.
then
out of those 40 courses that you have
to take to graduate with a for your degree these six
are
the most important
And you can see here that computer programming is
only a small part of.
Computer science computer science is the
mathematical discipline.
More specifically it is Applied Mathematics.
Let's go through these items quickly. So we have computer program.
Of course.
Where you learn things like functions variables?
control statements like for loops
FNL statements right right classes objects that
kind of thing.
Then we have perhaps what is the most important of
them all for at least if you're a software engineer or a data
engineer you'll be you you will have
to be a master of data structures and algorithms.
So this is perhaps the most important course of
them all.
And in order for it to be a master of this very important.
topic
you need to be able to read and understand.
the contents
In discrete mathematics. So if you were to pick up a discrete mathematics textbook
and really we can cover discrete mathematics
in one that's in one textbook, which is
not true for
a subject like probability Theory or
Calculus for sure not calculus it will take a couple of books to cover.
at least a linear algebra even
so you will need multiple books to refer to.
if you want to be good at this book, whereas the screen mathematics
really I'm you can there are
a few books
There are soft contain and those alone you can you can
learn a lot from those at those books. My point.
Is this really if you want to be an elite software
engineer and Elite Daily engineer
if you want to be able if you want to be someone who's able to
work with and produce very
You know Advanced algorithms for solving very complex
problems. Then you have to be a master of data structures.
And in order to be a master of data structures. You
have to be if we proficient into discrete mathematics.
But moving on.
the first three are very mathematical in nature the
next three are very
You know.
Hardware related or
Applied Mathematics, so we have computer networks, which
is systems that facilitate communication between computers.
The Internet is a very big part of a course
on computer networks operating systems.
An operating system is the biggest unit of software
on any computer.
and then computer architecture, which is how
You are able to interface with the hardware through
software.
so if we have the computer hardware
then we have an abstraction called computer architecture and
then we have low level programming language and then
on top of that you have a high level programming language like python,
Java.
A PHP JavaScript Etc.
So if you want to be a master.
of computer science
These are the six topics you need to you know
know very well.
but if you want to go
to the next level
and be able to work on all kinds of
algorithms then
your priority would be data structures and algorithms.
and in order to get to that point
you must
be very comfortable with discrete mathematics.
Which is what we were about to talk about.
today